welcome to this video a new rapids game
2510 does capitale listen it's a funny
handle never heard of that one okay so
what do we get maybe a Queens gambit
that's very done or I've been only
what's what to do here not sure I want
to go for the NIMS Oh again now maybe
play here and get them exchange
variation yep the translation of that is
read the capital gap probably referring
to dust capital x marks so I'm playing
that fashionable line with night h5 oops
it's not trading that's uncommon no okay
I'm gladly taking the bishop here how to
set up the pieces now hmm okay
everything about
that confirmation looks a bit awkward
but it doesn't it's not necessarily bad
one important thing is that he has very
good control over a five so like Knight
f3 knight to e5 this could be something
okay I'm starting with this trying to
provoke um yeah that belief that move
and now queen is channel the idea is
that if he goes nighty too and okay
that's that's impossible a queen trade I
did not I don't mind really let's take
check maybe takes with the g night and
miss places it no okay but it was it was
some it was them I guess okay for you to
play for that idea let's see
hmm yeah interesting question is if I
really if i should still castle in this
position or not
yeah that's debatable what's a good
setup here still a bit worried about 925
I mean not like I'm in the state of
panic but still what to do about it be
great if I kept in her meal like with
Bishop g4 iOS has aged three damn i'm
really not sure but i think probably
castling is still right so if i go like
Knight f6 he has that 95 move so I don't
like it that much Straub Lee what is the
good setup night to e6 probably not ok I
have to have to start with yeah trying
to connect the roofs oh I think Bishop
g4 was a threat he didn't react to that
playing immediately all the time but
that was a threat I'm threatening rupee
eight now winning winning material
I thought you had to react to that idea
somehow with age 3 or f5 or whatever
quite resigns yeah that's probably
probably a bit early but it's not a good
position 91 is what you can play check
check 93 and let's say something like
that that was the setup that I was
thinking of with f6 to prevent the jump
something like this it's likely to
happen and here i guess i prefer black
heads it's it's it feels a little bit
like I have an extra pawn due to the due
to the double pawn but it's not a
position to resign and then any any case
maybe he didn't really see 91 but yeah
if you play a 25-10 game and you have 27
minutes on your clock at the end of the
game and you lost there's a pretty clear
explanation for what went wrong or what
you did wrong um gap okay Bishop f4 ism
is a bad move i guess white normally
takes and goes like this then something
like this is a pretty typical way it may
add forward like there should be six
long castles sometimes in the modern
games even castle shorter in this this
type of position um the black is fairly
okay here Bishop f4 l KL it gives me the
bishop pair and the better structure
check yeah I thought I thought um up by
the way that's an interesting move
didn't really think about it and rookie
one is a threat I have to do something a
bit awkward now because I cannot castle
maybe you can change them that it's not
not really a big issue right but that's
definitely okay for white I mean more
that's an advantage for what ok and ok
after that very comfortable and now he
has to react somehow but maybe that's an
even better actually if we if I think
about it like this i cannot interpose
because of f6 and now this kind of thing
it might be better actually like f6
night back Bishop g2 as the threat not
bad at all I bet it on ok again a pretty
short game iya in that pool thanks for
watching